tell everyone so welcome to another
episode of unlocking lily it's always
been my dream to be a speaker where I
can inspire people to do extraordinary
things and a few months ago
I decided to make a life-altering
decision I quit my day job to pursue
this full-time and you guys are all
coming along for the ride
with me so every challenge that I take
on is to help me grow as a speaker so my
challenge this time is my first
corporate gig with sage summit which is
a two-day business conference I'll be
taking part in a mentor lounge where
people could come in and book one-on-one
coaching with me and talk about two
specific areas the first area is
leadership and vision and the second one
is attracting and retaining talent so
when Evan surprised me with this
opportunity to be part of Sage summit I
was so incredibly excited look at this
it's exactly what I want I am so so
grateful for this opportunity and then I
started to think oh I actually have to
go out there and be courageous and show
up and answer people's questions and be
someone's mentor what if I go there and
I sit there by myself and no one shows
out to talk to me how am I good deal
with that rejection what if everybody
wants to talk to me and I have nothing
to say
what if people ask me questions that are
way above my head and I completely make
a fool out of myself what then and
that's when I was like no no this is
ridiculous I need to stop thinking like
this obviously Evan recommended me
because he believed I am qualified and
capable to do this amazing great whoa
what if I let him down
you know it's his name on the line here
he vouched for me I have to perform well
what if I fall flat on my face and now
he feels like he made a mistake in
recommending me what do I do that
that's what I thought about something
that was quite interesting about me all
my life I never feel that I'm worthy of
the things that happened to me I lean
into the gratitude a lot I mean I'm so
grateful for Evan for giving me the
opportunity I'm so grateful for all of
you for supporting me but I never give
myself credit that I have worked hard
for something that I do deserve it and I
am worthy and that's what I thought you
know what I need to really change my
mindset around it yes of course I'm new
and yes I'm very grateful for all the
opportunities are coming my way and it
wouldn't happen unless you know Evan was
helping me out but at the same time my
intention is pure my intention is to add
as much value as possible my mission is
to help people become extraordinary and
as long as I keep that in mind and work
really hard to prepare myself to show up
and say hey you know I am qualified to
do this and I am ready and prepared and
I spent the last couple of weeks you
know really really really preparing and
getting ready for this event
then if things do kind of go wrong which
it will things are never perfect I can
learn from those mistakes and I can use
this as an experience as long as I know
that my intention is to help others my
intent is that about the mentees are
going to be coming in
it's not about me freaking out and being
panicky if I'm panicking they're going
to be panicking too it's my job to stay
calm and provide them with a great
experience and know that this is why I'm
doing this in the first place so when I
thought about all of that it immediately
gave me the excitement which is great
and also the confidence to go and
continue on and feel great that I'm not
only incredibly lucky to be given this
opportunity I also deserve it
because I've been working so incredibly
hard towards this goal so excited for
this
good morning everyone so today is
actually the big day
so it's about 5:00 5:15 a.m. I'm an
early-morning riser so this is amazing
for me this is like the best time of the
day for me where I can reflect and kind
of start my day right and see what are
the things that I need to do so the
first thing that I do after I get
dressed and shower and everything is
actually do a walking meditation so what
that is is I look at the at the
environment around me and just focus on
that
so for example if I were just to look at
these trees for example I just focus on
the leaves I focus on the color I don't
think about anything else about that so
I'm going to do that quickly for about
five minutes or so and then I'll see you
very soon
[Music]
so I finally ended up in the exhibition
grounds where the series coverage is
taking place so I'm just following the
crowd and hopefully I'm going to find it
and rivers ahead of me hopefully they're
going the right direction and you'll
meet up with Evan very very soon he's
here already so early so I got my badge
and I see Evan oh this is so weird this
is so meta look at look who it is
Lily it's filming put it there
oh no your says new to stage look at
that ah all right
maybe people will be nicer to me we're
going to head inside soon
I gotta do two back-to-back mentoring
sessions and I think overall went really
well if people laughed really happy with
the first one I feel like I could have
done more with his limiting belief I
could have dug a little deeper and given
given the situation I kind of hesitated
so anytime I hesitate I don't end up
following through the way I want I still
think he left off with a lot tons of
value but he didn't actually get to the
real issue that he was facing so I
definitely needed to change that and
then the second one I was able to take
the immediate feedback that I gave
myself and I started asking more
important questions right away so that
way I could get to the solution a lot
faster and yeah I think I still could
have got there a little bit faster than
I did better better but it could have
been I could have been faster and I
could have helped him a lot more with a
solution and helping his business and
how to create his messaging around
what's important in him but in the end
what made me really happy because he he
left and he says I'm going to start
doing this right now it's going to be
this afternoon and thank you for tea
thank you for helping me take immediate
action and that to me is the the biggest
thank you someone could give you so I
feel really good
tomorrow I'm back at this again and I'm
going to try to find ways to get to the
problem a lot faster than I have been
and that's been an ongoing progress for
me so yes I'm really excited for
tomorrow but super pumped about the two
mentees that I had today
so today is a day two of sage summit I'm
just thinking about the two mentoring
sessions that I had this morning and how
much joy that brought me I always
approach any kind of mentoring session
or coaching session with a lot of
nervousness because I'm always worried
that I'm not adding enough value you
know what are the things that I could do
better and then once I have a person
face-to-face everything else kind of
fades and I just focus on them and the
things that they can do to inspire
themselves so really thinking about the
two people that I had yesterday and how
happy they were when they left and how
they going to take immediate action I
actually received an email from one of
them saying that his day went you know
from a seven and a half to eleven and he
wanted to thank me for that so all of
that makes it so worth it to wake up at
4:45 in the morning to get down there
and to do the mentoring session yeah I
don't know it's that's why I do what I
do is to see other people happy is to
see them getting inspired is to see them
taking action right away whether if it's
in their life or business or
relationships whatever it is that they
need and I'm going to just take that
with me this morning and I feel a lot
less nervous I feel way more excited
than nervous so it's all good it's going
to be a great day it's the last day of
the summit so it's it's going to be a
fabulous day yeah
all right just got out of the keynote
with Rick Mercer I'm going to head over
to the mentor lounge
I think Evans already here let me go
find him all right day two of the summit
done overall it was a really great
experience I haven't been to an
accounting conference before and who
knew that it would actually be a lot of
fun the keynote this morning I don't
really need to be honest I didn't know
who he was for those of you don't know
he is a Canadian comedian any coaching
coaching sessions but I use the
opportunity to learn from Evan I had
some questions for him so he kind of
guided me through that and I was right
beside him so I kind of sit in and he's
drop a little bit into his sessions and
learn from him and see what he does so
that way I could use some of that method
myself too and see the weekends question
looking at his thought process all of
that so overall it wasn't a waste even
though I was looking forward to meeting
more people but every opportunity is an
opportunity to learn oh great great
so being part of the sage summit was
such an incredible experience for me not
only did I get to mentor people help
them out with their business and lives I
got to watch some great speakers deliver
their message to us I also met a new
friend her name is Rebecca she shared
her favorite quote with me which is say
yes and figure the rest out afterwards
which basically sums up this entire
experience for me when Evan came with a
challenge I just said yes I had no idea
what was expected of me I didn't know
the details I didn't know where I needed
to be at what time what day wherever I
just said yes and it turns out to be one
of the best experiences I've had in a
very long time and I'm so glad I said
yes so for my next challenge I'm going
to be
bringing all of you behind the scenes in
my mentoring sessions with Evan I
learned from Tony Robbins that success
leaves Clues if there's something you
really want to be successful at you need
to study and mentor under someone who
has been there and it has been
successful consistently and to me
I've been perfectly embodies that and
such a great mentor for me so the
question of the day is what is that one
scary thing that you said yes dude that
turned out to be an amazing experience
for you so thank you so much for
watching your comments and encouragement
who really received gets me excited and
wants me to keep going and making all
these videos for all of you as you have
a special shout out for Jason beam Jason
beam wrote this is so cool honestly
Jason you've been there since day one
and I'm so incredibly honored to have
you on this journey with me once again
thank you so much guys I love you all
and I'll see you very very soon